[Music]
facebook
twitter youtube instagram
snapchat tick tock new platforms
constantly appear
some grew big some disappear but did you
know that 3.78 billion people
are using social media every day in 2021
this is 48 of the world's population
facebook alone has over 2.32 billion
active users every month and we
the users spend an average of 2.5 hours
per day scrolling on our screens
social media have revolutionized our
society and our daily lives
for some aspects it did so for the good
allowing us to stay in touch with our
friends
helping us find jobs or simply having
access to information
social media also created room for free
speech
for dissidents and whistleblowers
[Music]
this is why authoritarian regimes like
china or belarus
do not like them and even banned them
but there is also the flip
side of the coin as more and more people
rely on social media as their main news
source
the more likely they are to believe this
information we now know these powerful
online platforms are used for spreading
fake news
hate speech harassment and conspiracy
theories
during the pandemic we experienced
online disinformation campaigns
on an unprecedented scale aimed at
undermining confidence
in western produced vaccines or making
us believe that
china or russia manage a pandemic better
than the eu
even worse as we saw in so many
elections to mention just the brexit
referendum
foreign actors used online platforms to
interfere and
undermine our democratic process and
democracies
but it was probably the capitol hill
riots in january 2021
that served as a wake-up call it's on
pro-trump facebook groups that the mob
got organized
to ravage the temple of american
democracy
and it's on twitter that trump himself
motivated his supporters
repeating his baseless claim that the
election had been stolen we're gonna
walk down and i'll be there with you
trump's facebook
and twitter accounts were finally
blocked or suspended by the platforms
but is it up to the powerful big tech
owners to take such decisions
today in europe we have almost no tool
to prevent harmful
activity taking place on these platforms
for the socialists and democrats
self-regulation is not enough we need
laws
not guidelines to increase platforms
accountability
while safeguarding freedom of speech and
avoiding censorship
no amount of people that we can hire
will be enough to review all of the
content we need more transparency
and clear rules about taking down
illegal content
including hate speech and incitement to
violence
and we need to fix the algorithms that
promote polarization
at the expense of constructive dialogue
we need to end the digital wild west
and protect our democracies
you